Today, Snoopy can be found on coffee mugs,
greeting cards and blimps, and even has his
own amusement park.
But Charlie Brown’s lovable black and white
spotted dog wasn’t always mainstream.
In fact, when the comic strip first appeared
in the 1950s, the dog and his Peanut friends
were considered, to quote Time Magazine’s
David Michaels, “the fault-line of a cultural
earthquake” due to the way the comic depicted
life, real characters, and sadness.
Garry Trudeau, the creator of Doonesbury,
went so far as to call Peanuts “the first
Beat strip… everything about it was different….
[it] vibrated with ’50s alienation.”
The story of Peanuts is the story of its creator,
Charles Schulz- the man who changed everything
about comic strips.
Schulz was born on November 16, 1922.
He would later state that a mere two days
after his birth, “an uncle came in and looked
at me and said, ‘By golly, we’re going
to call him Sparkplug.’
So, I’ve been called Sparky since the day
after I was born…”
Somewhat fittingly, this nickname was in reference
to a horse, Spark Plug, from the Barney Google
strip.
Schulz was an only child and often talked
later about his feelings of isolation.
With the freezing weather in St. Paul, Minnesota,
no siblings, and an introverted personality,
he could be found most days reading comics
by himself, with his life’s ambition even
from childhood to be a comic artist.
As to why, Schulz stated,
When I was growing up, the three main forms
of entertainment were the Saturday afternoon
serials at the movie houses, the late afternoon
radio programs and the comic strips.
My dad was always a great comic strip reader,
and he and I made sure that all four newspapers
published in Minneapolis – St. Paul were
brought home.
I grew up with only one real career desire
in life, and that was to someday draw my own
comic strip.
Schulz was also quite smart and skipped two
grades in elementary school, with the result
being even more isolation and inability to
make friends among his older classmates.
It was in high school where his artistic skills
began to take off.
Even late into his life, Schulz would show
off the collection of his early works, though
the school yearbook rejected printing any
of his submissions.
Beyond this perceived failure, Schulz also
stated in an interview with Johnny Carson
that high school didn’t go nearly as well
as elementary school academically- “I was
a bland, stupid-looking kid who started off
badly and failed at everything.”
A few years after finishing high school, now
at the age of 20, Schulz nearly simultaneously
experienced two abrupt life changes.
The first occurred in February of 1943 when
his mother died from cancer, with her last
words to him reportedly, “Goodbye Sparky,
we’ll probably never see each other again.”
You see, Schulz had recently been drafted
and set off for basic training days before
her death.
Unsurprisingly for a young man who just lost
his mother and was soon to experience the
horrors of WWII, his drawings from that era
were ones of depression and isolation.
He would later state of his time in the army,
“The army taught me all I needed to know
about loneliness.”
This all seems to have eventually worked out
for the man who once stated, “You can’t
create humor out of happiness” and whose
first wife, Joyce Halverson, said he told
her on their honeymoon, “I don’t think
I can ever be happy.”
She further claimed, “He said he wouldn’t
go to a psychiatrist because it would take
away his talent.”
Schulz would further note in an interview
in 1997 with Charlie Rose, “I suppose there’s
a melancholy feeling in a lot of cartoonists,
because cartooning, like all other humor,
comes from bad things happening.”
Upon coming back from the war, he devoted
himself to becoming a full-time artist, first
teaching at Art Instruction Inc., and eventually
getting his first real cartooning job at a
Catholic publishing company where he lettered
a religious comic book called Timeless Topix.
Schulz stated of this job,
I eventually would letter the entire comic
magazine in English, French and Spanish — and
at one time I think I even lettered it in
Latin, I’m not sure.
And for this [Roman Baltes] gave me $1.50
an hour — I was just to submit my time — and
I was always very efficient.
He would call me up during the day when I
was working at Art Instruction.
‘Sparky, I’ve got some things here and
I sure would like to have them by tomorrow
morning.’
So I would drive from Minneapolis all the
way to downtown St. Paul — sometimes taking
the streetcar if I didn’t have my dad’s
car — pick up what he wanted, which he left
outside the door, and then go over to Art
Instruction for the day.
I enjoyed it thoroughly, and I could letter
very fast.
One day I had done a special fast job for
him, and as a reward he let me draw a four-page
story which had something to do with some
soldiers or something, and then he actually
let me do two pages of humor cartoons, and
some of them were little kids.
After they printed two of them, for which
I think I got $20 a page, he then said that
the priest who was running the outfit didn’t
care for those, so that was the end of that.
Nevertheless, his work at Timeless Topix got
him enough local attention and experience
that, in June of 1947, he managed to get hired
by the Minneapolis Tribune to draw a strip
he called Li’l Folks.
Still living in his father’s basement and
getting paid ten dollars per comic (about
$111 today), Schulz was in heaven.
One can absolutely trace the origin of Peanuts
to Li’l Folks- from the well-dressed boy
who loves Beethoven to a dog with human traits
to a bald-headed kid named Charlie Brown-
named after a colleague of Schulz’ at Art
Instruction.
The tone was also similar- a mixture of loneliness,
sadness, sarcasm, and outward expressions
of childlike joy.
Schulz would later say that many of his characters
in both Li’l Folks and Peanuts came from
real-life inspiration.
For example, Schulz noted, “The first dog
I ever had was a Boston bull named Snooky.
She got run over by a taxicab when she was
about ten years old and I was about twelve…about
a year later we got a dog named Spike, and
he was the inspiration for Snoopy…
[Spike] was the brightest dog I ever met.
He had a vocabulary of at least 50 words – words
he understood, that is.”
Looking to name his comic dog after his real-life
one, he was disappointed to find out that
another comic at the time already had a dog
named Spike.
So, he tried Sniffy but that was also already
taken.
Finally, he settled on “Snoopy.”
As for the character that would eventually
take the lead, Charlie Brown, this seems to
have been most closely inspired by the man
himself, though it’s generally thought that
all the characters embodied elements of Schulz’
personality.
For instance, Schulz once revealed in an interview
that Linus, among other things, represented
his spiritual side.
But as for Charlie Brown, said Schulz, “I
worry about almost all there is in life to
worry about.
And because I worry, Charlie Brown has to
worry.”
Or as Charlie Brown once so succinctly stated,
“My anxieties have anxieties.”
Continuing the parallels, his father, Carl
Schulz, was also a barber the same as Charlie
Brown’s dear old dad.
On top of this, the red-headed girl Charlie
Brown always longs for but never attains also
mimics Schulz’s real life one time flame-
a red-haired woman by the name of Donna Mae
Johnson, who Schulz proposed to, but who turned
him down and not long after married someone
else instead.
Going back to Li’l Folks, Schulz attempted
to get it syndicated into newspapers across
the country, which was generally necessary
for a comic artist of the day to make a career
of the job.
But for three years, there were no takers.
Things finally changed when United Features
Syndicate expressed interest in the then 27-year-old
Sparky Schulz’ rather unique comic.
But there was a problem- there were already
comics out there with similar titles, like
Little Folks and Lil’ Abner, so a new name
was needed.
As for what the name should be, that choice
was taken out of Schulz’ hands when it was
decided at United that the comic should be
called The Peanuts– borrowing from the name
the TV show Howdy-Doody had for its on-stage
audience of kids- the Peanut Gallery.
To the day he died, Schulz hated the name
“Peanuts” calling it “the worst title
ever thought of for a comic strip.”
In fact, he himself avoided using the name
whenever possible, stating, “If someone
asks me what I do, I always say, ‘I draw
that comic strip with Snoopy in it, Charlie
Brown and his dog.’”
In an attempt to phase out the name, at one
point he tried to give the strip a subtitle-
“Good Ol’ Charlie Brown”- but that name
didn’t catch on.
It was forever Peanuts.
On October 2, 1950, the comic debuted in seven
newspapers, including the Washington Post,
Boston Globe, and New York World-Telegram
& Sun.
Even the first comic strip was slightly off-kilter.
It depicts two kids sitting on a curb as a
joyous Charlie Brown skips past.
“Well!
Here comes good ol’ Charlie Brown,” says
the sitting child (who would become Linus),
“Good ol’ Charlie Brown, yes sir.”
The final panel reveals the child’s real
feelings with Brown now out of view, “How
I hate him!”
At a time when comic strips were dominated
by action-adventure, slapstick, marriage humor,
and melodrama, Peanuts was different.
The comic expressed sadness, anger, depression,
isolation, insecurity, and inferiority.
While it was funny, it also did it at the
expense of some of the taboos of the time.
For example, in the first panel of the March
27, 1959 edition of Peanuts, Lucy sits at
her cardboard box with “Psychiatry help
5¢” scribbled on the side.
In the second and third panels, Charlie Brown
sits down in the chair and tells her “I
have deep feelings of depression.
What can I do about this?”
After considering for a moment, she tells
him, “Snap out of it.
Five cents please.”
Depression was rarely talked about out in
the open in the 1950s, much less in a comic
strip.
Lucy’s advice – which she always gave
and always made Brown feel worse – was a
paraphrase of the typical given at the time-
as in it’s on you to choose not to be depressed.
However, it’s clear that Schulz knew better.
Not only that, but even the artistic style
of the comic was different.
As the creator of Calvin & Hobbes, Bill Waterson,
once noted,
Back when the comics were printed large enough
that they could accommodate detailed, elaborate
drawings, Peanuts was launched with a tiny
format, designed so the panels could be stacked
vertically if an editor wanted to run it in
a single column.
Schulz somehow turned this oppressive space
restriction to his advantage, and developed
a brilliant graphic shorthand and stylistic
economy, innovations unrecognizable now that
all comics are tiny and Schulz’s solutions
have been universally imitated.
Watterson would go on,
Every now and then I hear that Peanuts isn’t
as funny as it was or it’s gotten old.
I think that what’s really happened is that
it changed the entire face of comic strips
and everybody has now caught up to him.
I don’t think he’s five years ahead of
everybody else like he used to be, so that’s
taken some of the edge off it.
I think it’s still a wonderful strip in
terms of solid construction, character development,
and the fantasy element.
Things that we now take for granted—reading
the thoughts of an animal, for example—there’s
not a cartoonist who’s done anything since
1960 that doesn’t owe Schulz a tremendous
debt.
That said, things started off slow for the
strip and at the end of its first year in
circulation a reader survey of comics conducted
by New York World Telegram put it dead last
in popularity.
Schulz kept churning the comic strips out,
however, and within a decade Peanuts was in
hundreds of newspapers across the country
and Schulz was beginning to be recognized
as one of the best comic creators in the world.
Never giving in on its ideals or dealing with
hard-to-talk about subjects, Peanuts soon
found its way on the cover of Time Magazine.
It also adapted to the times, bringing in
characters that continued to push the envelope
in a changing world.
For example, in 1966, Schulz introduced Peppermint
Patty- a tomboy who wears shorts, open-toed
shoes, calls everyone by a nickname, and lives
with only her dad.
Peppermint Patty was quickly the strip’s
most complex, fully-realized character, who
dealt with the political issues of the day
without hitting the reader over the head.
Yet, she still possessed a similar inferiority
complex as almost every other character in
the strip- always believing she looked funny
and wasn’t quite good enough.
Moving on to 1968, a few months after the
assassination of Martin Luther King, Schulz
introduced Franklin, Peanuts‘ first black
character, who attended the same classes as
the white students, became friends with them,
and whose father fought in the Vietnam War.
As you might imagine, however, adding Franklin
to the mix was not without controversy, even
before a strip with him was ever published.
As Schulz said,
I finally put Franklin in, and there was one
strip where Charlie Brown and Franklin had
been playing on the beach, and Franklin said,
“Well, it’s been nice being with you,
come on over to my house some time.”
Again, they didn’t like that.
Another editor protested once when Franklin
was sitting in the same row of school desks
with Peppermint Patty, and said, “We have
enough trouble here in the South without you
showing the kids together in school.”
But I never paid any attention to those things,
and I remember telling Larry at the time about
Franklin — he wanted me to change it, and
we talked about it for a long while on the
phone, and I finally sighed and said, “Well,
Larry, let’s put it this way: Either you
print it just the way I draw it or I quit.
How’s that?”
So that’s the way that ended.
In the end, Peanuts went on to branch out
into TV specials, movies, and best-selling
books.
According to Forbes, for a time Schulz was
one of the highest-paid entertainers in America,
during his heyday estimated to have been earning
in the realm of $30-$40 million per year,
while Peanuts appeared in over two thousands
newspapers and was translated into over twenty
languages in over 75 countries.
On top of that, gross revenues from all sources
of revenue related to Peanuts combined saw
it bringing in in excess of a whopping $1
billion annually at its peak.
All told, nearly 18,000 editions of Peanuts
were published- and, unlike so many other
famed comic artists who ultimately resorted
to hiring assistants to help out, Schulz drew
every single edition of the strip.
However, in the late 1980s, the artist began
to develop tremors leaving his lines wobbly.
Said Schulz, “It’s just annoying, It slows
me down, and I have to letter very carefully.
After my heart surgery, it was intolerable,
and then I wracked up my knee playing hockey.
That was worse than the heart surgery; it
just took all the life out of me…I just
couldn’t hold that pen still.”
Nevertheless, he still refused to let anyone
but himself draw the comic.
Finally, in late 1999, he suffered a series
of strokes and would also undergo treatment
for colon cancer, with the net result being
he was no longer physically capable of making
new strips daily.
He said of this,
I never dreamed that this was what would happen
to me.
I always had the feeling that I would probably
stay with the strip until I was in my early
eighties.
But all of a sudden it’s gone.
It’s been taken away from me…
And so it was that in December of 1999 he
announced his retirement.
Mere months later, on February 12, 2000, Schulz
died – a day before his last Sunday strip
appeared.
In the end, Schulz summed up his comic as
something of a primer on disappointment.
After all, as he said, “All the loves are
unrequited; all the baseball games are lost;
all the test scores are D-minuses; the Great
Pumpkin never comes; and the football is always
pulled away.”
Despite all this, however, Charlie Brown and
all the other characters show an admirable
amount of fortitude and resilience when faced
with never ending stumbling blocks- they simply
never lose hope and never stop trying.
On that note, unlike so many other successful
comic artists who contemplated quitting in
their early days as the rejection letters
piled up, the obsessive worrier Schulz somehow
never lost faith that he would eventually
achieve his dream.
Said Schulz,
To me it was not a matter of how I became
a cartoonist but a matter of when.
I am quite sure if I had not sold Peanuts
at the time I did, then I would have sold
something eventually; even if I had not, I
would continue to draw because I had to.
The
aforementioned art instructor Schulz named
Charlie Brown after, Charlie Francis Brown,
once stated in an interview that he got in
a little temporary hot water with a police
officer when the officer demanded his name.
This prompted Mr. Brown to reply, quite honestly,
“Charlie Brown.”
The annoyed officer apparently didn’t believe
him.
Charles Schulz once sagely stated, “A cartoonist
is someone who has to draw the same thing
every day without repeating himself.”
That’s a tall order for someone who created
nearly 18,000 strips- and it wasn’t always
easy.
On this note, Cathy Guisewite, creator of
the comic strip Cathy, revealed in an interview
that Schulz once called her in something of
a panic as he couldn’t think of anything
to draw and was doubting whether he’d be
able to come up with anything.
Exasperated, she stated, “I said, ‘What
are you talking about, you’re Charles Schulz!’…
What he did for me that day he did for millions
of people in zillions of ways.
He gave everyone in the world characters who
knew exactly how we felt.”
One of the most famous Christmas specials
of all time- A Charlie Brown Christmas, had
its genesis in a conversation TV producer
Lee Mendelson had with representatives from
Coca-Cola.
They asked if Schulz had ever considered making
a Peanuts Christmas special, to which Mendelson
stated in the affirmative and a deal was quickly
made for the special.
Mendelson then called Schulz, telling him,
to quote Mendelson, “I had just sold a Charlie
Brown Christmas show.
He asked which show and I told him, ‘The
one we’re going to make an outline for tomorrow.’
And we literally did the outline in one day.”
Unfortunately for the pair, when the program
was screened by CBS executives, they were
less than thrilled.
They didn’t like the jazz soundtrack; they
didn’t like the fact that real children
did the voices of the characters; they didn’t
like that the program lacked a laugh track;
they didn’t like A Charlie Brown Christmas
– end of story.
Their official verdict was, “this is probably
going to be the last Peanuts special.
But we’ve got it scheduled for next week,
so we’ve got to air it.”
When A Charlie Brown Christmas made its debut
on December 9, 1965, it was seen in over 15
million homes, topped only by the wildly popular
Bonanza.
It amassed glowing reviews, critical acclaim,
as well as an Emmy and a Peabody award.
Well spotted CBS.
When Schulz’ first wife, Joyce Halverson,
discovered the then 47 year old Schulz had
been having a several month long affair with
a 25 year old Tracey Claudius who he first
met at a photo shoot, she demanded he end
the affair.
Not long after, Schulz published an edition
of Peanuts in which Snoopy laments, “What
do you do when the girl-beagle you love more
than anything is taken from you, and you know
you’ll never see her again as long as you
live?”
Snoopy then is shown at his food dish, stating
“Back to eating!”
Ultimately Schulz and his wife divorced.
As for his perspective, he would later state
in an interview, “I didn’t think she liked
me anymore and I just got up and left one
day.”
Within a year of that, he married another
woman, Jean Forsyth Clyde, who he met at his
hockey rink.
The couple stayed married for 27 years until
his death in 2000.
The character of Franklin would help inspire
a young Robb Armstrong to go on to become
a cartoonist himself, eventually creating
the famed Jump Start comic strip.
Many years later, Schulz would ask permission
to give the character of Franklin the last
name “Armstrong” in homage
to Robb.